[Musique]
elle est entrée dans l'histoire en
devenant la première est encore
aujourd'hui la seule femme première
ministre de france elle est restée aux
commandes pendant presque onze mois sous
la présidence de françois mitterrand
entre 91 et 92 un moment de sa vie qu'on
lui rappelle systématiquement et qui
éclipse peut-être tout ce qu'elle a fait
par ailleurs son combat pour une europe
plus forte et plus solidaire par exemple
sa fondation qui a permis de créer des
dizaines d'écoles de la deuxième chance
sa mission d'élu local en tant que maire
de châtellerault pendant 14 ans les
arcades du pouvoir les connaît par coeur
c'est une partie de son monde depuis
près de 60 ans elle va nous le faire
découvrir de l'intérieur bienvenue dans
un monde un regard bienvenus edith
cresson et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
c'est un peu vrai ce que je disais on
vous ramène systématiquement à cette
période de votre vie à cette courte
période vous avez été premier ministre
oui c'est le seul pays disons parmi les
pays comparables à la france ça se passe
comme ça il ya une femme premier
ministre portugal longtemps avant moi on
n'a pas posé des questions de ce genre
quand madame thatcher a été premier
ministre au royaume uni je sais pas je
sais bien que c'est pas la même le même
système parce que au royaume uni le
premier ministre et élu alors qu'en
france la constitution veut que le
premier ministre soit nommé par le
président n'empêche que j'avais été élu
comme vous l'avez rappelé le maire
député conseiller général j'avais été
cinq fois ministre et la seule chose
dont on parle encore maintenant la
preuve c'est ça donc quoi d'après vous
n'ont cessé
ceux spécifiquement français c'est un
phénomène spécifiquement en france ce
qu'on appelle le pouvoir entre
guillemets doit appartenir aux hommes on
ne sait pas pourquoi mais enfin c'est
comme ça et quand il ya une exception à
cette règle ça prend des proportions
extraordinaires moi j'ai vu tout entendu
sur ce sujet est encore la preuve ça
continue donc j'aimerais bien qu'un jour
les choses se normalisent que la france
soit comparable à ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays pays disons comparable
pays européens
on n'a jamais vu mais vous avez bien
conscience d'être encore aujourd'hui un
symbole pour beaucoup de femmes
politiques aussi puisque c'est à la fois
un succès et peut être un échec parce
que ça a été très bref et on va y
revenir mais c'est aussi un succès
d'avoir été vous êtes encore la salle
aujourd'hui femmes premièrement je ne
sais pas si c'est un succès je sais que
la seule chose que je sais c'est que
j'avais quitté le gouvernement avant et
j'avais créé une entreprise c'était
après la chute du mur de berlin j'avais
créé une entreprise pour aider les
entreprises françaises à s'installer
dans les pays de l'est j'avais fait ça
avec didier pineau valencienne ça
marchait très bien et jusqu'au jour où
françois mitterrand m'a appelé pour me
dire qu'il souhaitait que je sois
premier ça j'ai commencé par refuser les
dix noms pourquoi parce que j'avais pour
moi c'était une page qui est tournée
et je faisais des choses qui me semblait
utile ce qui m'intéresse dans la vie
c'est de faire quelque chose qui est des
résultats est premier ministre on n'est
pas utile
d'autres ces parcours n'est pas utile
c'est pas ça c'est qu'il y avait
beaucoup de concurrents c'est à dire que
tous ces messieurs voulait être premier
ministre surtout que c'était là le
deuxième mandat de françois mitterrand
c'était la deuxième partie du deuxième
mandat donc la pire période puisque on
s'acheminait vers la fin et tout ces
messieurs étaient enragés à l'idée que
ne serait pas pour rien mais des
vitrines avec ça en tête donc je savais
que j'aurai beaucoup d'ennemis à
l'intérieur et que ce serait extrêmement
difficile c'est pour ça que j'ai refusé
il a tellement insisté il était malade
star donc j'ai fini par accepter vous
avez le sentiment d'avoir dû en faire
dix fois plus que les autres et que
notamment les autres zones de vous et
vous est ressorti endurci de cette
expérience un dur sinon je crois pas
mais parce que c'est exactement ce que
je pensais qu'ils allaient se passer
enfin pas à ce point là oui pourquoi pas
à ce point là qu'est ce qui a été qu'est
ce qu'il ya des pommes dépasser votre
votre image à notre comportement notre
trahison permanente le fait qu'il
parlait aux journalistes y raconter des
mensonges
c'était c'était terrible donc c'est vrai
que c'est je savais que cela serait
terrible mais c'était encore pire que ce
que je pense vous parlez d'une
expérience qui a été difficile et on
l'entend notamment parce que vous étiez
entouré d'hommes qui voulaient votre
poste qui ne voulait pas d'une femme
première ministre est ce qu'à un moment
donné vous vous ai demandé si vous vous
aviez peut-être fait des choses avec
maladresse avec une est-ce que vous
aviez une part de responsabilité dans le
fait que ce soit bref 11 mois ou que les
choses se soient mal passé oui
certainement je dois faire des
maladresses mais le problème n'est pas
là je suis pas la seule donc pour une
femme on pardonne absolument rien et on
invente surtout des choses qui sont
totalement fausses on ne prêtait des
propos que je n'avais jamais tenues
qu'est ce que vous auriez malfait vous
pensez à quelque chose quand je vous
demande si temps je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas mais certainement j'ai dû faire
des choses que dire des choses qu'il
fallait pas mais
on
ne s'occupe pas si vous voulez les
journalistes surtout mais ils étaient
amis certains journalistes sont amis
avec des hommes politiques et marchent
ensemble et donc
ce que je faisais du tilt n'était jamais
on n'en parlait jamais donc on cherchait
toujours les choses négatives et quand
on cherche on trouve j'ai la main edith
cresson comment vous y est devenu à la
politique comment l'étudiante hec que
vous étiez se décide un jour à se dire
tiens je vais y aller je vais me lancer
moi aussi on en est là c'est très simple
quand j'ai fait à ce sujet j'avais une
amie qui s'appelle paulette de craine et
dans le père était un ami de françois
mitterrand et elle m'a raconté que
pendant la guerre quand elle était
petite un jour on sonne à la porte elle
va ouvrir elle voit un jeune homme qui
lui dit dis à ton père que françois
morland et la morlande se défendant de
résistance et donc
après hec elle a travaillé avec lui et
c'est elle qui m'a fait venir qui m'a
dit tu devrais venir cet intéressant ça
s'était longtemps avant 81 et je
travaillais au parti socialiste j'étais
chargé la jeunesse des étudiants
et j'ai beaucoup appris donc ça m'a
intéressé ensuite on a envoyé à
châtellerault côté réputée imprenable
on va y venir à cette expérience d'élu
local mais peut-être j'ai lu vous allez
me dire si je me trompe ou pas j'ai lu
que c'était aussi un discours de pierre
mendès france sur la jeunesse qui vous
avez décidé qu'ils vous qui vous avaient
motivé pour entrer en politique c'est
vrai ou pas oui une figure importante
j'avais beaucoup d'admiration pour plus
en inde et france c'est vrai oui
pourquoi qu'est ce qui fait que ces
policiers l'ont lui qui vous aident et
fassent plusieurs raisons d'abord parce
qu'il s'intéressait avec un ami il n'y a
pas beaucoup d'hommes politiques qui
s'intéresse vraiment à l'économie qu'il
avait beaucoup de bon sens il me semble
que c'est très courageux ah oui j'avais
de l'admiration dans l'ue
parler d' hec vous parler d'économie se
sont pas forcément les sujets qu'on
traite à la gauche pourquoi le parti
socialiste oui mais ça compte l'économie
on le vit aujourd'hui bien sûr donc à
toute une mode dans la classe dominante
politique française pendant très
longtemps par exemple on disait que
l'industrie c'est fini je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez l'industrie c'est
fini maintenant c'est les services les
complètement idiot parce que chaque
emploi industriel créé trois emplois de
service et puis s'il ya pas de
l'industrie il ya pas de recherche on ne
progresse pas eu aujourd'hui on est dans
une phase de révolution industrielle
totale et si on est mauvais dans ce
domaine là il est évident qu'on peut pas
exister et on existe dans le rapport de
force internationale que quand on a une
certaine puissance économique longtemps
à cette expérience d'élu local que dont
je parlais en introduction
maire de tueur est d'abord puis de
châtellerault
1977 puis 1983 6 ans puis 14 ans
d'expérience c'est pas rien comment
s'est passé comment la greffe a pu
prendre à l'époque on aurait pu parler
de parachutage peut-être même qu'on a
parlé de parachutage et finalement la
grèce va prendre oui bien sûr c'est ce
qu'on appelle un parachutage mais enfin
je n'étais pas la seule et quand je suis
arrivé à châtellerault j'ai été séduite
par cette ville c'est une ville ouvrière
c'est la région qui pendant la guerre a
été la plus résistante dans l'ouest de
la france il ya une manufacture d'armes
il y avait une population ouvrière très
très intéressante est d'ailleurs la
première fois que je me suis présenté à
l'élection le maire de la ville
mais si la blinde terre gelée battu sur
sa ville de châtellerault pas dans
l'ensemble de la surface fétiche cas du
premier coup mais je les battues sur sa
ville donc je me suis dit il ya quelque
chose à faire ici et j'ai eu un
sentiment
j'ai pas de d'affection vis-à-vis de
cette ville sa population vous avez été
vous même surprise par ce sentiment
c'était pas votre univers s'était pas
votre milieu je connaissais pas du tout
chapellan je savais à peine où c'était
et quand on m'a envoyé là effectivement
j'ai eu comme une espèce de révélations
ça m'a beaucoup touché qu'est ce qui
vous a touché chez eux j'ai le courage
de ces gens
cette population ouvrière
qui était très impliqué
s'intéresser à la politique qui était
plutôt évidemment plutôt de gauche et
des gens très courageux vous savez à
poitiers était une ville
universitaire on dit chatellerault c'est
une ville ouvrière avec un petit peu de
distance moi je disais je suis très fier
d'être le maire de lille aurélien et
j'ai beaucoup aimé élire une femme n'a
semble-t-il pas été un problème pour eux
pas un sujet à aucun moment de cette
expérience d'élu local on vous a renvoyé
au fait que vous étiez une femme et que
peut-être vous étiez moins compétente
qu'un homme absolument pas alors la
différence de la classe politique à
châtellerault ça n'a posé absolument
aucun problème jamais jamais se poser
plus de problèmes à paris elle est d'un
an femme est d'être une femme achète je
savais quand une femme arrive à
l'assemblée nationale vous savez bien
comment ils sont il insulte enfin c'est
à tel point que
l'actuel président de l'assemblée
nationale après une décision c'est à
dire ceux qui l'insultent les femmes on
va leur prendre la moitié de leur
rémunération du mois suivant cette
relation vous avez à paris m'intéressent
j'ai envie de creuser un tout petit peu
parce que vous avez été aussi celle qui
a décidé de transférer l'ena à
strasbourg c'est que vous avez été dans
cette démarche de décentralisation
cette démarche de décentralisation comme
vous dites elle était dans le programme
commun de la gauche et il n'y a pas que
les noms on parle de l'ena mais il ya eu
des dizaines aide and administration qui
ont été décentralisés
parce que y'a pas de raison que ce soit
à paris et il faut aussi que d'abord ça
irrigue le le tissu local et puis les
gens adhèrent mieux à l'administration
dont il voit effectivement les membres
donc c'était dans le programme commun de
la gauche et donc je n'ai fait
qu'appliquer le programme et parmi
toutes ces décentralisations y avait
effectivement l'ena pourquoi strasbourg
l2 strasbourg est une ville symbolique
très belle d'ailleurs qui est un symbole
dans l'histoire française et d'autre
part parce que le parlement européen
siège partiellement strasbourg je
pensais que ces jeunes seraient comme sa
familiariser avec une réalité locale et
européenne on le dit peu et les français
le savent peu mais votre monde c'est
aussi et c'est même surtout j'ai envie
de dire l'europe j'ai retrouvé
évidemment votre discours de politique
générale du 22 mai 81 11 vous faites de
l'europe une priorité pour vous il
fallait et je vous cite faire réussir la
france dont l'europe de 1993 et dans le
monde l'an 2000 est-ce qu'elle a
finalement réussi cette europe cette
france dans l'europe partiellement mais
c'était l'objectif en tout cas de
françois mitterrand est d'ailleurs de
ses prédécesseurs aussi le construire
l'europe la france seule évidemment pèse
mais pas suffisamment et la construction
européenne a été poursuivi par tous les
présidents de la république et françois
mitterrand lui a fait franchir une étape
supplémentaire avec le traité de
maastricht qui développait les
politiques communes dans beaucoup de
domaines beaucoup de domaines différents
par exemple domaine éducatif avec le
programme erasmus qui permet à des
étudiants de circuler en toute l'europe
de connaître mieux leurs homologues et
puis
pour françois mitterrand c'était
effectivement un objectif majeur je peux
le comprendre
pour la france c'est très important
c'est pour ça que c'est toujours un peu
difficile parce qu'il ya quelquefois des
décisions qui se prennent à l'unanimité
quelquefois des pays comme actuellement
certains pays à l'est
qui sont un peu réticents et encore
cohérente cette europe est ce qu'elle
est la cohérence que vous souhaitiez
cette europe quand on voit effectivement
des vrais contradictions des vrais pays
qui parfois ne partagent même plus nos
valeurs effectivement je pense à la
pologne je pensais à la hongrie elle
marcherait europe elle fonctionne pour
vous oui elle marche mais ça n'est pas
facile je pense que peut-être
faudrait-il sur ce gratin objectif se
limiter à quelques pays peut-être pas
avec tout le monde c'est à dire d'abord
cessé d'élargir l'europe et est ce qu'on
l'a trop élargi cette europe elle est
élargie pour une raison objective ces
pays sont européens et par ailleurs
certains pays de l'est sont entrés
peut-être un peu rapidement dans l'union
européenne c'est le chant c'est l'école
qu'il souhaitait ça
et je me souviens que au moment où on a
discuté de la monnaie unique qui est
quand même un symbole très important
françois mitterrand voulait la monnaie
unique et les allemands ils savaient
qu'ils étaient réticents parce qu'il
tenait aux marques qu'ils étaient menés
très forte très fort et donc
ce moment là françois mitterrand a
demandé à col de ne pas faire voter les
allemands sur la monnaie unique parce
qu'ils savaient qu'ils voteraient contre
et cole en a profité en disant oui je
les ferai pas voter sur la monnaie
unique mais
je voudrais que les pays de l'est de
l'europe en tout de suite en or ces pays
n'était pas prêt du tout mais pourquoi
est ce qu'ils ne voulaient c'est parce
que c'était des sous traitants pour
l'industrie allemande des sous traitants
relativement bon marché il y avait un
calcul alors oui il y avait un calcul
bon alors c'est un donnant-donnant le
françois mitterrand et bien sûr ça va
tout ça et il a accepté donc c'est vrai
que ces pays à cause de ça sont en train
peu rapidement dans l'union européenne
ll vous inquiète cette europe
aujourd'hui
on peut se poser des questions oui mais
enfin il faut continuer il faut essayer
de la fortifier et on voit bien
aujourd'hui
les états-unis la chine
bon mais ce sont des pays unique ciblées
avec plusieurs pays c'est toujours plus
difficile c'est pour ça que je pense que
dans certains domaines peut-être
faudra-t-il faire des accords sur des
points limitées est-ce que parmi les
sujets qui vous préoccupent il ya
l'environnement je vous pose la question
parce que là aussi dans ce discours de
politique générale de 1991 vous dit la
notion d'environnement ne doit plus
rester extérieur au processus de
production mais s'y intégrer là on est
en 1991 ce sont des phrases qu'on entend
encore aujourd'hui ça veut dire que vous
avez presque était visionnaire en disant
191 mais ça veut dire aussi que c'est
toujours pas fait non bien sûr mais
c'est un grand un vrai travail mais
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours été
sensible aux problèmes d'environnement
et à l'intérieur du parti socialiste
j'étais chargé de l'agriculture
avant avant la création des partis
socialistes il est là ce qu'on appelle
la convention des institutions
républicaines et j'étais chargé de
l'agriculture et l'environnement donc ça
veut dire que c'est une préoccupation
qui même avant 81 habitaient déjà ce qui
constituerait plus tard le parti social
vous étiez seul à penser à
l'environnement à l'époque un sentier
seul ou pas c'est un combat qui
paraissait non je ne me sentais pas
seule la preuve c'est que
j'avais ce titre donc c'était accepté
par l'ensemble du parti oui sauf que
parfois il ya des titres qui sont
honorifique mais qui ne servent pas à
grand chose et c'était peut-être moins
évident qu'aujourd'hui mais c'était
quand même déjà une préoccupation qu'il
existait un effectif mais comment vous
la voyez cette question aujourd'hui
alors qu'elle est devenue majeure
elle est majeure très difficile
heureusement que les états unis
maintenant tu un peu évolué mais depuis
trump qui niait l'existence de ce
problème mais c'est sûr qu'il faut s'y
atteler d'une façon
très très sérieuse est un problème
extrêmement difficile parce qu'on
connaît mal
les effets
de certaines décisions et donc il faut
apporter une attention à mon avis encore
plus grande à ce problème
d'environnement aujourd'hui parmi vos
combats signé aussi ces écoles de la
deuxième chance est ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler vous auriez aimé vous
avoir une deuxième chance c'est pour ça
que vous savez moi je veux dire des
écoles de la deuxième chance sont faites
pour les jeunes qui n'ont rien appris à
l'école
et donc y en a beaucoup j'ai vu beaucoup
de jeunes sortis
de leur période scolaire ils savaient à
peine lire bon donc quand j'étais à la
commission à bruxelles j'ai fait un
groupe de travail et on a décidé de
faire les écoles de la deuxième chance
c'est à dire des écoles où pourrait
aller les jeunes qui n'ont rien appris
et où d'une période qui peut durer de
six mois un an avec des stages en
entreprise on ne réussirait alors faire
obtenir les les données de base lire
écrire compter et puis un peu de
connaissance du monde économique et
j'ai réussi à ce que le parlement
européen vote cette décision
cette décision était assorti d'un budget
qui était attribué à chacun des pays de
l'union européenne les au pays je
l'aurais donné l'argent mais pour la
france je les gardais en disant je vais
le faire moi-même parce que si je donne
ça l'administration ça va être mort et
donc je cherche une municipalité que ça
intéresse j'ai trouvé marseille est le
nerf de la cei monsieur gaudin était
très intéressé par le sujet et je lui ai
donc donné l'argent pour le prototype
puisque cet argent était destiné à faire
un prototype de ces écoles dans tous les
pays il a eu son école gratuite et à
cause de ça grâce à cela j'ai pu faire
venir des municipalités de partout voir
comment ça fonctionnait et donc beaucoup
d'autres
villes on crée des écoles de la deuxième
chance et aujourd'hui il y en a
évidemment beaucoup il ya à peu près 16
ou 18 mille jeunes aux parents qui
passent par ces écoles et avec un
résultat positif à plus de 70% edith
cresson d'un petit rituel dans cette
émission c'est ce qu'on appelle ou ce
qu'on va après la séquence photo j'ai
plusieurs photos à vous entrez vous
allez me dire laquelle vous avez envie
de commenter dans un premier temps j'ai
celle ci avec simone veil et jacques
chirac j'ai aussi celle ci avec françois
mitterrand vous lui souffler à l'oreille
peut-être allez vous nous dire ce que
vous lui souffler à l'oreille à l'époque
et j'ai aussi celle ci à vous proposer
alors ce sont trois de vos ministres des
figures politiques absolument majeur
encore aujourd'hui que vous avez vous
même lancé j'allais dire dans l'arène
politique et peut-être que vous en tirez
une certaine fierté laquelle avez vous
envie de commenter dans un premier temps
peut-être celle avec simone veil bon ils
sont toutes intéressantes effectivement
simone veil gelé connu c'est une femme
remarquable
très intéressante première présidente du
parlement européen
très discrète jeter au parlement
européen quand elle était présidente
enfin c'est toute une histoire je veux
dire toute une légende si on veut donc
j'ai beaucoup de sympathie et d'amitié
bon simone weill est d'allier des bonnes
relations oui le train très bonne
relation très bonne relation vous diriez
qu'elle a été un modèle qu'on aime part
d'une certaine façon et elle a été un
modèle je peux pas me comparer mais
c'était une femme du fait de
l'expérience terrible qu'elle a eu dans
sa jeunesse
je crois qu'on sorte de cette épreuve
certainement tout à fait différent donc
ça ne peut pas comparer avec les
banquiers n'a pas connu ça une femme
politique aussi qui a oeuvré
peut-être un modèle en politique
absolument une deuxième photo alors elle
et elle est intéressante cette photo
elle nous a paru à la fois sympathique
et peut-être avec un certain sens vous
aviez l'oreille attentive de françois
mallinjoud par la lorraine peut-être que
là des gens avec je souhaite pas qu'ils
entendront la fin avant c'est sûr vous
vous cachez vous lui souffler à
l'oreille souvent vous aviez vous
pouviez me confier des choses lui
conseiller des choses il vous écoutait
il était attentif à ce que oui les
couteaux ils étaient attentifs à tous
les gens que les buts par là et ça veut
pas dire qu'ils faisaient toujours ce
que c'est quand même le conseiller mais
oui il était très attentif et là aussi
quelles étaient vos rapports
vous entendiez bien humainement vous
étiez lucide l'un et l'autre sur la
raison pour laquelle il vous avez nommé
premier ministre
c'était france était dit rien c'est à
dire que quand il m'a nommé premier
ministre dans la discussion que nous
avons eue il m'a dit je veux qu'une
femme était premier ministre avant la
fin de mon mandat et je me dis peut-être
qu'il aurait fallu y penser plus tôt
parce que la deuxième partie de deuxième
mandat c'est la pire période évidemment
parce qu'ils sont tous à vouloir la
place et puis le président moins
d'autorité dans la fin du deuxième
mandat surtout qu'en plus c'était très
malade donc je lui ai dit ça et il a
senti vos difficultés
misogynie ce sexisme auxquels vous étiez
qu'on a inventé la santé associés en
parlant des journalistes qui nantais
comme il pouvait
edit il ne vous lâcheront jamais
ils le savaient qu'il a sous-estimé
le côté machiste à la fois de la classe
politique et journalistique parce que ça
marche ensemble
et voici donc ces trois ministres ces
trois personnes qui ont été dans notre
gouvernement dominique strauss kahn
martine aubry jean yves le drian vous
ressentez une certaine fierté de les
avoir lancés de voir qu'ils sont encore
importants absolument
c'est moi qui ai réussi à faire nommer
martine aubry et dominique strauss kahn
le drian s'est pas uniquement moi c'est
à dire françois mitterrand avait dans
l'idée mais
ça n'a pas été simple d'imposer martine
aubry par exemple s'il s'agit est très
facile il
ne connaissait pas mais enfin je lui ai
expliqué qu'ils s'étaient parce qu'elles
travaillent avec moi déjà j'avais chez
des groupes de travail quand j'étais
ministre des affaires européennes et
pour réfléchir aux affaires européennes
et j'avais fait venir des gens d'un peu
partout après une certaine expérience
pour me conseiller en avait des groupes
de travail on travaille ensemble elle en
faisait partie et j'avais je l'avais
remarqué à cette occasion et donc
jusqu'à ce que vous aimiez chez elle son
sérieux sans
sa rigueur voilà une très grande rigueur
beaucoup de sérieux beaucoup de
conviction aussi beaucoup de sagesse on
a une autre séquence dans cette dans
cette émission c'est la séquence
archives puisque les archives nationales
nous faut un bonheur chaque semaine de
nous transmettre sinon un original au
moins une copie d'un document historique
on a pensé à celui ci pour vous
et là vous êtes avec boris elstine c'est
une photo prise à l'occasion d'un
déjeuner en l'honneur du président de la
fédération de russie en est alors en
1992 vous êtes aux côtés de roland dumas
ministre des affaires étrangères à quoi
vous pensez à ce moment là qu'est ce
qu'elle évoque pour vous cette photo
les liens avec la russie ouais je pense
que nous devons avoir des liens avec la
russie quel que soit ce qu'on peut
éventuellement reprocher le gouvernement
russe
je pense que surtout depuis la chute du
mur de berlin depuis la fin on peut dire
de l'union soviétique
la russie traditionnellement on est une
alliée de la france et je pense que
c'est une erreur de sous-estimer
l'importance de la russie dans la
configuration mondiale les états unis la
chine l'europe avec toutes les
difficultés qu'on a puisque c'est pas un
seul pays il faut arriver à s'entendre
et nous devons tendre la main on a vu la
russie même avec une
russie avec un vladimir poutine aux
commandes ont elles mêmes avec poutine
devant à mon avis c'est la russie cet
angle les russes c'est un très grand
peuple
qui a évolué en dehors du système
mondial à cause du système communiste
mais quand on voit en russie
et moi j'y suis allé souvent
on est surpris par
le niveau ces gens parler les
scientifiques remarquables des artistes
magnifique il ya une vie intellectuelle
intéressante et je pense que dans ce qui
se passe actuellement encore une fois
avec les états unis la chine l'europe
devrait avoir des liens avec la russie
un mot de roland dumas qui est aussi à
vos côtés ce jour là là aussi une
personnalité politique qui vous a marqué
roland dumas ou enfin j'en ai pas de
très bonnes relations avec lui pourquoi
c'était quelqu'un
[Musique]
enfin jeu c'était très difficile très
difficile quand j'étais ministre des
affaires européennes déjà il était
ministre des affaires étrangères et la
vie à ses collaborateurs de ne pas me
donner d'informations donc une raison
pour laquelle j'ai quitté le
gouvernement
et puis après il a fait deux trois coups
tête
c'était très difficile de s'entendre
avec lui c'était quelqu'un qui
travaillait surtout pour lui-même est ce
que vous êtes une des rares ministres
avant démissionner effectivement c'est
extrêmement grave il avait un problème
avec vous en particulier
il avait un problème avec tous les gens
dont il pensait qu' il pouvait empiéter
sur son territoire dans les affaires
européennes
considéré que ça faisait partie des
affaires étrangères et donc
je n'avais pas d'informations il avait
interdit à son cabinet nous donner des
informations donc c'était très difficile
un drôle de monde en ce monde politique
tel que vous le décrivez monde difficile
très difficile
c'est un milieu où à part certaines
exceptions il a quand même des
exceptions heureusement mais les gens
ont tendance à travailler pour le même
edith cresson une dernière question qui
est en lien avec ce lieu magnifique dans
lequel nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
sommes entourés de quatre statues il
représente 4 vers et argent qui sont
magnifiques la sagesse la prudence la
justice est derrière moi l'éloquence est
ce qu'il ya une de ses vertus qui vous
parle plus que les autres dans laquelle
vous vous reconnais que la justice
pourquoi parce que
c'est un élément très important ce très
difficile
de définir ce qu'est la justice mais
c'est que
chacun soit reconnu en fonction de ce
qu'il est réellement et non pas en
fonction de ce qu'on raconte sur lui et
je pense que la justice est une vertu
fondamentale
occuper sa place de jouer son rôle
d'exister et les pieds pas c'est le
contraire de cette pièce de mépris que
l'on rencontre assez souvent quand vous
parlez on a l'impression que vous parlez
aussi un peu de votre parcours à vous on
a été injuste avec vous vous auriez vous
avez été victime dune
c'est arrivé je suis pas la seule j'ai
pas la seule sarah merci infiniment
régressons d'avoir été avec nous dans ce
grand entretien sur public sénat merci
nous avoir livré un peu de votre monde
est en tête votre regard sur le monde
merci à venir si c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve très vite sur
public sénat
[Musique]
je